you do you think you'll play video games
for the rest of your life yeah you do
forever
yeah I mean yeah I mean less there's no
such thing as them like they got rid of
them you're not but you're not you're
you're not gonna have kids right or
you're gonna have kids sir how long you
do so I would be essentially a single
mom raising a kid right so don't do that
that's the only reason why I've been
like I have so many trepidations is
because I know how he functions day
today yeah and even with the animals he
loves them a lot but he doesn't know how
to act like our dog Julio was von phul
you know Esther dry-heaving on the bed
instead of helping Julio to get off the
bed he just pushes yeah pushes the
animal while he's vomiting that makes
sense
would you do that with a kid no do you
think that would switch it's it's so
funny because to me when I see a lion
riot you see a lot of lawyers hat right
I know the difference and even if I had
that was a better analogy there's a
really about it but still I throw it out
I know what you mean I throw out there
though you're saying you have such my
connection with you know my kids would
be different than my connection dogs
yeah how do you know that like that's
not a guarantee I don't know but how do
you know I will be a bad dad no no no
that she does a lot of people say people
say people that know me say over the
that you'd be a good father who say who
says they don't live with you date today
I'm just saying people have said El
Madrigal I said it he's sweet and cuddly
but so that's why they're Shaina
raised chill yes they're saying that cuz
you're a sweet guy cuz you have a great
deal birth set it let me ask you this
look at me right now and be honest be
honest with me go ahead alright yeah
be completely honest with me you know
what if they made wag for kids yeah now
we great them you can have someone come
walk that's a business plan that we
could have well then I well don't you
always tell me what run we won't run
them but no but yeah well hire people
hire people but let me out be honest
with me yes I were to ask you if
somebody to ask you hey Bobby Lee's
having a kid with kalila what do you
think of that what would you say was my
initial reaction yep be real disbelief
like what how would you say it verbally
or just kind of just neutralize it let's
play it out okay so go ahead so Who am I
I'm some kind of joke my name is Joe and
I'll be a guy that
no I'm Neal Brennan be a comedian that
we're all right okay
I'm Frankie the guy that would the
doorman at the store great hey Frank
what's up
amen um you're late for your spot no no
I'm actually always are oh that's right
yeah my bad Oh anyway hey Gigi to the
new news what Bobby Lee and kalila
they're having a baby really yeah Wow I
guess I would have never that's [ __ ]
Wow okay
that's really yeah that was so real oh
here's what I did my next I was so real
my next thought would be like I didn't
think like of course they've been
together they have sex but I thought
they'd have sex like like all lesbians
have sex no penetration that gets a lot
of touching and emotional yeah that's
tough but I guess well it's our pop man
they're gonna go through with it huh
just ask you this
yeah keV I'm Frank are you seeing that
um may be real with me yeah you think
that my genitals can't penetrate a
vagina or produce a kid maybe you don't
think that the fluids within me are
active I don't think they're working oh
oh but they are how do you know because
we've had we've had to you've had two
abortions yes walking down this that's
what I think I would be I would love to
be a godfather to your kid will you dad
thank you for throwing that out there I
would love I would love my hat and every
would an option you'd be and I'm trying
to kind of have a kid right now yeah
really yeah but you know what it really
comes down to oh I'm scared I'm scared
to raise a kid in LA yeah me too cuz I
didn't grow up here I have this [ __ ]
I know it's faking it's crap and it's
stupid I have this fantasy of raising
the way I got raised how's that in
Chicago I just have this thing about
like I want him to feel the way that I
felt about things when I was a kid it's
selfish and [ __ ] up and it doesn't
matter but like there's a thing about I
want to be able to take my kid to a
[ __ ] Chicago Cubs game
that's what I grew up with with my dad
not there's anything wrong taken with
Dodger game it's just it's it's a world
that I'm like this doesn't mean as much
to me because I didn't grow up here Ryan
but you're wrong
I know no no I'm right in my feelings
but it's it's not it's a stupid way to
think I feel the exact same way yeah I I
asked you this yesterday yeah if we have
kids can I take them to the Philippines
can i I want them to have the same
education that I did they went I went to
an international school I was really
immersed than a lot of things I had a
really really enriched life growing up
and I had a very a good sense of like
how the world outside of America was you
know doing things yeah and I want that
for my children I don't want them to be
cultured I want them to are you afraid
they would have no culture here
no not I'm afraid of that but I don't
want to living their rich life right I
just don't have everything because Bobby
is even with animals he spoils them and
I just don't want a spoiled kid you'll
have you'll have one you will inevitably
have one with him yeah I think so
what not a percent you know the you know
these kids that like grow up in Orange
County
you know these pieces of [ __ ] mm-hmm all
of them every single one of them yeah
but that's not the kind of I'm joking
you know I'm kid I just see something
right now let me make my point let me
make my point go ahead your kid will
inevitably be extremely spoiled and well
taken care of because of the life you
live because of the way you live your
life there's no way that you won't have
a spoiled brat
kid it'll be impossible to avoid your
kid will be a [ __ ] brat like I don't
want to have a kid that doesn't know how
to take public transportation he will he
or she won't
horeb you'll have a spoiled brat kid you
know I I I'm offended by that is there
anything that you wouldn't be offended
by that because something right now yeah
I'm offended by that because I'll tell
you something right now
what is is that my parents were wealthy
and they gave me everything Poway yeah
so you went to my school
yeah San Diego is nice right I grew up
in like a place called Green Valley I
know a fancy right it's fancy
yeah escort country club blow thing and
I was a [ __ ] up kid time out yeah your
parents are from Korea that's right so
you're the your first generation yeah
okay what does that mean you look at
your parents had a lot of money but they
treated you with values based on the
well yes
they threw no they threw me camps and
cars and everything but you [ __ ] it up
I [ __ ] it up because I was a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] ok so your child but can I
say this don't [ __ ] it up we'll be a
good kid but we'll be spoiled rotten
know it yes it doesn't matter where or
what or when it's because you're
successful now it's all it's all it's
it's a lottery system you having a kid
you don't know you don't know for sure
I know dudes that are like you know
really bad people with great [ __ ]
parents who are bad people yes Ted Bundy
Ted Bundy yeah he had great parents took
him to church they did I read the book
okay okay yeah you're gonna be a great
dad
thank you your kids good here's the plan
here's the thing here's the thing though
dude I do kind of want to raise my kids
in LA because um there's nothing wrong
when I hear other kids raised here yeah
it's kind of cool like you know when
like I was hanging out with Oliver on
set yep and I go yeah we had these kids
on my podcast called the ruin brothers
yeah I was telling him they sound like
Roy Orbison he's like oh yeah I grew up
with his kids yes oh you like that he's
like yeah I used to go over there yeah
he's a cool dude you want our kids to
just run and he just kind of one-up me
like I was like I know a band that kind
of sounds like him but he was like oh I
know the real dude but you know that's
that's what this that's that's what I
like but that but it's a never-ending
competition in LA that's life
nope life is a never-ending competition
in life no no no cuz it's not because in
LA it's one-upsmanship oh so you don't
think the two plumbers in Chicago right
go ahead keep your brothers right they
had their parents with Mario and Luigi
yes Italian plumber yes I go down the
pipes which is kind of strange yeah yeah
oh yeah they go down
Yeah right right if I was a plumber at
every job yeah while I was fixing the
pipes oh here we go
Benna nananana really good Hey
yes let's skip to it let's go to
something else what I will say this
you'd make great [ __ ] parents I'm
just saying I I'm saying this for me I
know when I raise a kid in LA I gonna
spoil them and try my best to give them
everything I didn't have yeah so
inevitably they'll probably be [ __ ]
brats I'll probably raise a brat because
I want them to have all the [ __ ] I think
that's a mistake to want everything for
them I know I shouldn't you but I also
I'm like they just also don't build that
much of a character but I know the
[ __ ] dud
yeah they'll be they'll be I know but
but then but the only way to like fix
that is to make them I what I should do
is have them and then ship them to
Alaska yeah and they can live off the
grid that's what Kevin Bacon did to
associate them away your son goes or
your daughter goes mommy mommy um the
whole school they're going to France
this is when she's 16 by the way France
and I want to go to Paris I want the
friends with the whole school
everyone everyone going to be too
[ __ ] bad you know the one thing that
I'm very thankful my mother taught me
yeah was her rejection and the word no
and I had to just eat it and I just had
to sit there and wave your other point
man I do you still have a relationship
yeah I do I mean she was really rough
and have a good one with mine [ __ ] on
but but but no doesn't you know I don't
spiral downwards when I hear the word no
okay the same kid comes up to me huh
you play my kid that they same cadastre
dad Wow your voice has changed oh yeah
yeah what is it son so like all all the
like or the whole class has taken a trip
it's it's school project that everyone's
going well it's like a class trip
everyone class is going well yeah it's
well no you don't it's elective but
everyone is going okay and what is it
worthy going Cabo San Lucas Mexico
oh but everyone's going almost okay
there's only one kid that can't go what
did mom say I haven't asked her yet oh I
was just thinking maybe what if every
kid's going and I get to go we're going
well you want to go yeah that's all I
really wanted yeah but mom won't go yeah
mom's going to I don't want her to go oh
I'm going to photos on Instagram with us
on the beach yeah so listen I had the
same thing my parents were very very too
[ __ ] bad I used to tell a bit about
it there's no too bad dad's anymore they
don't exist but my parents were too bad
no a lot of knowed a lot of too bad but
that's also the way that we grew up but
I know living in this town it's
different
this town is different it is different
and now I'm not [ __ ] on LA I'm just
saying I just know it's different I just
all my friends with kids and they tell
you and they're like you know you have
to [ __ ] apply for kindergarten you do
that's crazy
not only that but you basically have to
move to [ __ ] Wonderland school just
to be able to go to somewhere okay and
if you if you raise your kids in San
Diego great no but I'm saying but that's
it but that's easier I'm gonna can I
just say my last point though is is that
when I was in Arlington
there was an Asian kid working there he
was 18 years old he was working at the
at the club at the club what was he
doing he was washing dishes or something
and he was Asian washing dishes he was
what he walked he brought like food like
chicken fingers or something he was like
he was in the kitchen I don't know what
he was doing but I didn't ask him what
but he's just a kid that works you had a
good connection with the staff I always
do so I go amen which
he said I forgot his name Lewis and I
got uh he's like what do you eat Korean
he goes not really not particularly I go
what are you you guys well I was adopted
oh he doesn't know yes I am Korean but
like I know anything about it I got Oh
Oh have you thought about like looking
for mine I don't give a [ __ ] mother [ __ ]
yeah I go whatever my parents what about
your parents no I think Amy love yeah my
dad's a psychologist my mom works at the
school white parents my parents yeah I
got you seem angry he's like yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] about life man really
a [ __ ] eighteen yeah I go I go well
you gotta figure it out he's like no I
don't have to figure anything out man
[ __ ] it I kind of like his attitude I'm
not gonna I'm just sayin and you walked
away and I looked at um Billy Bonnell
and I was like um wow that's weird and
it's like in my head I'm like it doesn't
matter where you grew up he this kid
probably had a great kit parents right
he was given up right public he
published raised in the right way maybe
he's come maybe or maybe not I don't
know we I don't know his past well I'm
gonna ask him when I go in a couple
weeks yeah you're gonna go in a couple
weeks my my point us is this is it that
you don't you don't know for sure no you
know it's not a guarantee that if I
raise kids in Chicago wherever you're
from right because they're great kid
they could be bad kid you're right so
it's like it doesn't matter so I'm gonna
get I'm not gonna move on LA and raise
kids somewhere else this is where I live
this is where my business is you have to
be here yeah so you do to being a good
parent doesn't guarantee you'll have or
a good location right none of that stuff
man it's a gamble so let's make a kid
yeah that's what I'm saying
wolf I'll get these guys the [ __ ] out of
here so we can do it it's so
[Music]